One of the cancer docu-series, Dr. Ellen Tark-Jensen, gave this recipe for liver,
cleansing, blended smoothie. I'm not going to read it all. I've been making the
strength for myself for a couple of times a week for several months now and the
last week. I am all of a sudden nauseous after I drink it. And he thought why this
could happen when I did it. He didn't bother me for so long. Yeah, I don't see
anything in there that's, you know, would spark red flag or anything. Usually when
you think of nauseousness after you eat something, you think of gallbladder. So
the only thing I would say is maybe I would ask the question, do you get
nauseous after you eat a fatty meal? Well, I don't know, I really thought of that.
Well, try to keep an eye on that. You do have a tablespoon of olive oil in here. And if, you know,
that will stimulate gallbladder contraction and if you have any blockage, you put the
duct or any slugishness of gallbladder issues, that could be, that could be an issue. What
are you doing for that? Well, you could do coffee animals, you could do hot packs over
the liver gallbladder area. You could go to the seven paces of detoxification course and look
at these four, which is gallbladder function and flow and see some hints about that with
that too, but that would be my first thought here, feeling nauseous and contraction.